chairing the meeting today so first of
all can I remind everybody of some
domestic arrangements can we please
ensure that our microphones are turned
off when they're not in use that we
don't interrupt other speakers and that
if we are attending the meeting and
speaking and we persistently interrupt
that meeting we may be asked to leave
can we all ensure our mobile phones that
are either on silent or switched off I
would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and by entering this meeting as a
speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
right before I move to the first item on
the agenda I think I better have
everybody note that I've decided to move
the cisco presentation and the cisco
report part 1 and part 2 to the
beginning of the agenda the minutes the
forthcoming decisions list and the work
plans will be discussed at the end of
the meeting and this isn't order to
ensure that the public interest is
served first so moving to the agenda
first of all apologies for absence and
substitutions do we have any such I will
go through the list as a roll call
before members to say where they're
present or not and so can you please
acknowledge when I ask you counselor
Sean Dawson I think I'll take that as
absent I can't actually see her
counselor Jane Gold here and go : good
morning counselor care Katherine Kathy
Grandin
I'm fairly sure I did see councillor
Grandin you might guess on councillor
Grandin I'm cute oh it's not working it
wasn't working properly can you hear me
yes I can hear you that's fine Thank You
counsel as the McCraw thank you doesn't
counsel Mary McClaren present
councillor Adrienne Osborne present
counselor
Terrence Carter present and good morning
good morning counselor James Caston
present morning counselor live in your
heading him present Casa Dave moola
present counselor key staff present and
councillor Keith Whelan present okay
item 2 on the agenda is to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members are
there any to declare okay item 3 on the
agenda to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme none received
and item 4 questions by the public none
received and item 5 questions by
councillors that is accepting kept
questions to the various reports none
received chair thank you very much so we
now move as I've stated earlier to the
change in the agenda we move straight to
item 9 on today's agenda which is Jos
1931 the capital investment fund company
Cisco Capital Limited business trading
and performance report for 2019 2020 I
want to state as we start the joint
overview and scrutiny committee we'll be
examining the business plan and I'm
fraid not the governance structures of
Cisco or the basis under which it was
set up or any decisions relating to that
or indeed its terms of reference and I'm
unlikely to allow a question
in those areas because they directly
fall outside the responsibility of this
committee today and I think would be a
matter for the full councils now please
note any questions by non-committee
members those present in the meeting
should be four points of clarity with
the item discussed because the debate
itself will be for the committee and
I'll ask that non-committee members wait
with any questions for clarity until all
committee members have completed their
questions we're going to go through
quite a rigid formal listing of members
to allow everybody an opportunity to
speak because we know that there are
sometimes time delays in these remote
meetings so first of all I think I could
introduce the board members of Safeco
Capital Limited who are here to answer
questions I would like to ask suggest to
them they could introduce themselves
briefly starting with crystal worth the
chair at Safeco capital yes hello good
morning everybody I'm here as Chris
Harris and I'm the giant chair scare
fest if go and we'll be starting a brief
presentation shortly when Yuri do we
have Henry cook yeah good morning Andrew
cook if I'm one of the two other
non-executive directors with a
background in finance and Mark sergeants
and yes good good morning everybody I'm
Marc sergeants and I'm also a
non-executive director of Cisco and a
chartered surveyor Thank You councillor
Rick mayor Councillor Rick mayor sorry
chair yeah councillor Rick mayor on the
mid Suffolk zip code board members I
believe we have apologies from
councillor Michael Holt councillor David
Busby good morning all right chair
Weber Holdings councillor Peter Gould
good morning I'm a member of the joint
holding and mid Suffolk holding board
company boards thank you now Nigel
Golder
good morning everyone and magical
director of jazz language Sal and an
advisor to shift K Neville Pritchard
good morning Neville prashanta
investment director at jll and advisors
Pacifico emily attack I'm Emily a tech
I'm the managing director of Cisco and
also the assistant director for assets
and investments thank you very much my
apologies for any mispronunciations I
may have made during those introductions
so members I do believe you forgot em
councillor Brewster I do apologize
councillor Brewster that's all right
Council on the gras yes I'm here and I'm
the chair of the holding company of
Sitka and the other companies from the
mystic angle do apologize reading from
Allah quite a long list here members we
now return or now turn to the report jos
1931 and I'd ask councillor Peter Gould
the mid Suffolk District Council cabinet
member for assets and investments who
will introduce the report thank you very
much Cass on the call I'm pleased to
support this report detailing cisco
capital's performance over the last 12
months and the proposed business plan
for the next 12 months the business plan
is a fundamental part of Cisco's
governance and ensures accountability to
each shareholders Safeco has provided
the councils with approximately three
million of net income since its
inception in 2017 approximately 1.6
million was received in the last
financial year and this equates to
approximately 10% of the council's
workforce cost or thirteen and a half
percent of council tax income this
income is essential and enabling the
council's to continue to invest and
deliver services within
districts sniff go forms only part of
the council's investment with funds also
been invested in the delivery of new
market and social homes and employment
opportunities across our districts the
capsules are due to start on-site with
the development of approximately 180
homes over the next 12 months
as well as investing in the delivery of
156 acres employment scheme in stone
market and in supporting our larger town
to adapt and thrive in the future no
investment is without risk
however the professional and strategic
approach adopted by Cisco in investing
and managing these funds for an income
return has demonstrated the resilience
of the portfolio even in these difficult
to covert 19 times SIF go collected over
70% of the March quarter rent and
consequently is able to make the full
debt repayment to the councils in March
whilst difficult times remain ahead with
a continued impact of Kovach 19 the
proposed business plan seeks to continue
the investment of the second tranche of
funds approved by the council last year
and in doing so to further diversify the
portfolio away from high street retail
focus instead on the industrial and
alternative sectors and - can you
continue to deliver and grow this
important revenue stream for the
council's and to create a long term
legacy for those councils the national
level the chairman of Cisco Chris Harris
and managing director Emily attack had
prepared a presentation to highlight the
key elements of the business plan and
performance over the last 12 months
other members of the board Henry cook
marks arkinson and Katz the RIC mayor
together with their professional
advisors Neville Pritchard and Nigel
gondor's are also here as you know to
take questions after
presentation see thank you very much
councillor McCool thank you very much
indeed
so now members we have the opportunity
here to ask questions but obviously that
being an introduction your questions may
be better held back until after the
presentation but the opportunity must be
given if there's any points on that
introduction that members would like to
raise what we shall do in each of these
questioning sessions is to ask each
member in alphabetical order regardless
of Council so if I go around the members
assembled councillor Terence Carter
they're not a swith point on your chair
councillor James Caston no questions
thank you Jeff counselor Shannon Dawson
okay
Leslie it's turned up councillor jangled
councillor Kathryn Grandin not at this
time thank you
you counsel Olivia Lavinia had Ingham no
questions thanks councillor Mary McLaren
yes I've just got one question
I just need clarification on the
different treasury management strategies
I don't understand that because we've
got the same board and the same officers
why is that different between mid so
Fagin Weber okay I think that wizard is
addressed in the report that perhaps
could be better attended to during the
after and after the presentation okay
that's right I think I think at the
moment we're not into specifics but I
believe it I believe it can easily be
addressed if you'd like to return to
that afterwards thank you probably
probably probably going to throw some
light on it councillor Dave Miller no
questions you present yeah Thank You
councillor Adrian Osborn Thank You mr.
chairman just one clarification you've
got David Busby mid suffered District
Council's holdings and you got Gerald
Brewster director PDC summit holdings
okay
accepting the fact that those should be
reversed apologies for that
I'm sure it can be let the record
reflect that they actually have the
opposite jobs to each other as it were
but they are both directors of the
holding
companies counselor Keith scarf no
questions at the moment thank you and
counselor Keith Wellum no questions at
the moment thank you okay
if there are any further questions from
members I think we're going to a cry and
attempt to use the raised hand function
but in testing before this meeting we
became aware that there is a slight time
delay and that hands aren't being raised
quickly and the system isn't raising the
hand quickly enough or removing the hand
quickly enough so with that lack of
responsiveness you may just have to wave
your hand about if I can see you on
screen for any other members present and
this is four points of clarity only are
there any other questions for members of
members of the council who are not
members of overview and scrutiny no in
that case we shall move on the chair of
Cisco capital Kris health and Emily
attack the managing director of Cisco
capital and our assistant director of
assets and investments were now jointly
conduct a presentation for Cisco before
we open for further questions and debate
over to you Chris and Emily Emily I
think you're going to share your screen
aren't you to give them the presentation
one second you see my screen now can see
EA at the moment I can't actually see
the screen but oh that's it I can see it
I hope everybody else can yes if
everybody can see that it hasn't reached
me yet all right
oh here we go give it a few moments
right I will do the first part of the
presentation and then hand over to Emily
so this is a summary of the business
plan for 2021 and I think next slide
please
I think it's important to bear in mind
the purpose of the business plan it's
certainly a very important part of the
company's governance it monitors the
performance of tsypko over the previous
financial year it provides a framework
and guidance for investment moving
forward and of course as directors we're
accountable against delivery of that
business plan next slide please
I just sort of get a very quick summary
of the market as it stands at the moment
obviously we do have Jones Lang here
with us and I'm sure they will be able
to answer any specific questions about
that afterwards but I mean as far as the
the UK commercial property investment
market is concerned the turnover in 2019
was significantly down from the two
years before you'll see that there's
about forty four and a half billion
compared to around 60 billion for the
two years previously and that's property
as a result of brexit uncertainty and
therefore a few opportunities coming to
the market the then after the the
general election in December that the
caused quite a resurgence in the market
and certainly q1 2020 the turnover was
four teamed just over 14 billion but
there were two very large transactions
in as part of that the the market
appeared to be moving forward quite
strongly and the fundamentals of your
contraction and rental growth can
continue to drive values particularly in
the industrial warehouse office and
alternative markets I mean as we know
shopping centres and high street retail
assets had a very hard time well before
the current coated 19 crisis really
because of the the internet shopping
increase and certainly
aboard we were not really looking at at
certainly high street retailer assets at
all over the last year or two retail
warehousing again seems was stabilized
and the the strong parts of the market
of the industrial warehouse office and
alternatives it says on the slide then
always we were then hit by the curve is
nineteen pandemic which caused a
complete lockdown and that meant that a
lot of transactions couldn't proceed we
had two transactions which we're looking
at which we put on hold because of that
and in fact we have probably we've
aborted one because of the crisis but we
are moving ahead with the other one and
and the what the quite what the pandemic
has done is it's increased focus on
quality assets and led to strong
covenants with long unexpired terms and
that's been the whole focus really of
the investment that we've done so far
interesting as we will see it shortly
into a really secure portfolio and one
of the aspects that came out of the
crisis is that um as far as valuation
was concerned the Maurya the our ICS
required value as to to put an
uncertainty clause into their valuations
because of the lack of evidence and this
is now they're now starting to lift this
again as the market is starting to to
move forward next slide please
so looking at the the portfolio the
total asset value is about fifty two and
a half million with the contracted rent
under point four million anyways the
estimated rental value of that if all
right reviews and everything had
happened as about three point six a
total number of assets of fourteen with
38 tenants then the the walt the
weighted average and expired lease term
because he is a good long period which
it's points towards a secure portfolio
to taking it account breaks in
is the average is six years eight months
and two expiring it's nearly eight and a
half years in terms of yield the initial
yield five point seven eight percent
that's really on the pass on rental
income on what we bought the properties
for the equivalent yield that's looking
at rent reviews and various other things
and full rental value and some of the
costs on the way six point four one and
reversionary yield was taken to account
the the rate of view is six point four
at the moment the void rate is just
under four percent and the running is
just under six percent next slide please
so during the year we acquired two
properties that's probably less than
we'd hoped but it's been as I said
earlier the been few properties coming
to the market but we have acquired two
one is the Honda car showman premises in
Milton Keynes which on its own is a good
solid investment but it's also as the
ally Davonte for us and that we own the
property next door and it is therefore
solidified a much bigger and more
sensibly shaped site in in that location
and that's that's very much a core asset
and then also we acquired an office
building in Epsom for three million
pounds a little bit of work there to the
possibility of adding that value so and
another good asset as part of the
portfolio next slide please
looking at the current portfolio waiting
between the first of all of the sector's
and also the covenant risk profile we
have ended up with a portfolio which is
far more secure than perhaps we'd
originally intended because of the sort
of opportunities which we found in the
market and what we thought were the the
right opportunity to buy so if you look
at them the covenant risk profile you
can see that the 89%
the covenants of tenants are very strong
there are some few smaller ones 4%
average and 7% weak now some of those
weak ones particularly there in little
industrial estates and actually that's
quite useful to be able to work rents
move things forward add value and
improve the asset by doing that in terms
of portfolio sector splits you can see
there the looking at the pie chart the
the largest section is office at 36%
there's a little bit of retail retail
warehouse at 10% high street retail at
15% alternatives at 13% and in that
comes car showrooms gyms things like
that and then industrial at 26% and if
you look at the the table there you can
see that we we we didn't buy any
opportunistic assets those are the
slightly higher risky risk ones where
there are more opportunities to add
value but we really couldn't find
anything we felt there was the right
price to reflect that risk and therefore
we've ended up with a portfolio at the
moment which is mainly core 83% that's
higher than we thought we would and some
core plus and if we move a move on to
the next slide you can see what our
target portfolio weighting was and I
apologize that the colors don't match up
with the slide before but if you look at
the target risk profile on the
right-hand side you can see that the we
had a a core target of 65 to 75 percent
whereas actually an 83 percent and 5
percent at value-add well we haven't
actually got any of the value added and
then looking at the target sector
weightings again offices were as you can
see in the slide before at 36% thenis
just slightly outside where we thought
we should be industrial and warehouse
we're at 26 percent and that's 25 to 35
percent so as we carry on and invest the
last 40 million we will adjust those to
get to what we think is a really good
well balanced well spread
failure next slide please looking at the
key investment criteria which that
really what guides us in our investment
decisions looking for a target portfolio
yield of about 500 quarter to six
percent and as it says in the small
lettering underneath it's investing in
secured income and that's the important
thing secure income going strong assets
with good quality and location now the
lot size is one of the changes we
brought that down slightly from it was
between 3 and 15 brought that down to 3
and 12 just to make sure the portfolio
as we continue an investment is well
balanced the regional biased as we said
before the weighting is towards the
eastern region it's not exclusively the
eastern region and we've ended up with
probably with about 40 percent of it
which is not within our definition of
the eastern region although most of them
are quite close quality locations which
we will continue to look at modern
fabric with occupational flexibility
obviously very important in terms of
relating buildings and things like that
fr for repairing and ensuring lease
structure and to make sure that the
tenants are responsible for the
buildings and if possible we like to see
RPI or open market upwards only and rent
reviews because that secures the income
so I mean if you look down the bottom
right there there are key assumptions
the further 40 million capital invest
and one thing the other thing that we
have changed in terms of the investment
criteria is that we've we originally
hoped to complete the full investment by
April of next year but because of what
has happened with the pandemic having
slowed everything down we think that is
sensible to say that we think that we
will do that and by 30 months rather
than by April and I think that's
important because we don't want to be
we shouldn't be out there buying things
because we think we've got to we should
be out there buying the right assets at
the right time at the right price and
next slide please so looking at the KPI
performance for 1920 the national issue
you're less initial yield which is
marginally above that so as the
equivalent yield is concerned we
reasonably significantly ahead of that
as far as the 24-month full investment
target to be achieved by April 20-21 as
I've just said we think we're going to
have to stretch that for a further
probably further six months for a
sensible investment period quarterly or
rent arrears now this is one where the
portfolio has been performing extremely
well but obviously we have had a
difficult time over the last quarter and
possibly in this quarter because of the
curve at nineteen crisis and let's go on
to the next slide and have a look at
that so we as far as the March quarter
is concerned this looks looks about what
happens there and the rent collected by
the fifth of June for the March quarter
was just over 70 percent but what's
important to realize about this that
said that that means that nearly 30
percent hasn't been collected yet but
yet is the important word because you
will see here that what as a responsible
landlord what we've done with with the
crisis is we've looked at working with
our tenants and the tenant in the good
old days it used to be thought that
tenants you know what you've got tenants
and got the landlord and now it's very
much a partnership so we have worked
with tenants to make sure that they can
manage some of the difficulties that
they've been having so you can see this
73 percent of rents has been collected
five percent of the the additional
amount is really on a monthly payment
plan to ease things for the tenant
20% of rents have been deferred and they
have been deferred they haven't been
they're not gonna be not paid they've
been deferred and looking at the risk
factor of those we don't think there is
a risk that we will not receive those
funds so once they be deferred they were
the funds we received in the future
there is also 1.4 percent of rents which
are not going to be received
because talented administration and
other matters like that
now obviously the June quarter will will
also be difficult but we will work
through it and on the same sort of basis
um now I will now hand over to Emily who
will take us through the rest of the
presentation
thanks Christy can everybody hear me
okay yeah good and so just moving on to
this slide this slide looks at the
income that has been received by the
council's and since Cisco's inception
and so from this slide you can see that
and the council's jointly have received
approximately three million pounds of
net income since and tsypko began
trading in 2017 in in the last financial
year twenty nineteen twenty the
council's benefited from one point six
three three million which has councilor
golf mentioned earlier is equivalent to
approximately ten percent to the council
staff costs or 13 percent thirteen and a
half percent of the council tax
collected by the authorities so the
you'll notice from this slide that the
net amounts are different for each
council and this is um a consequence of
the treasury management strategies that
both councils have employed and in
effect and Baber has a different mix of
loans and which it helps to support SIF
go with to mid Suffolk so mid Suffolk
has more long term loans
where
Weber has more short-term loans and
these are different interest rates and
it's the cost of borrowing that has the
the impact on the different net receipt
effectively so currently Babers
borrowing is cheaper than mid suffix
which is why there's a different net
figure they both receive receive the
same gross amount effectively moving on
i'm in 1920 and Sysco accounts are
currently being finalized as we speak
but the draft account show and a book
loss of approximately three and a half
million pounds this three and a half
million pounds and is the impairment
effectively and equates to approximately
half a million pounds worth of
acquisition costs now these relate to
the costs of the assets that were
required throughout the year so in
effect stamp duty and professional fees
which tend to be broadly and about six
and three-quarter percent of the the
cost of the asset and there is a further
impairment which relates to the
portfolio revaluation which was
undertaken as at the 31st of march and
saw a downward adjustment of
approximately five point six six percent
and which equated to about 3.1 million
and the value of property will fluctuate
as a consequence of market fluctuations
and while some individual property
values will and be more affected so for
example the retail market is seeing a
lot of structural change and we're
seeing more shift in valuations and as a
consequence other individual properties
may be more resilient to certain market
conditions which is the benefit of
having a diverse portfolio there will
also be fluctuations in value and with
individual properties depending upon and
where they are in their lease
ichael with assets where new leases have
been granted being at the the sort of
peak of their value whereas those that
are nearing the end of their lease cycle
will will be within that valuation curve
and towards the the lower aspect of
their value and then as the lease is
renewed then then they will increase in
value and over the past did at the lease
cycle process and whilst these and while
tsypko is showing a loss of three and a
half million and it is in effect a book
loss and that loss would only be
realized in the event that the assets
were sold cific Oh continues to deliver
income and to the councils and indeed
that was the purpose of Cisco being
established to provide that long-term
income to the councils within the report
and we also mention the Public Works
loan board consultation and which is the
government has issued a consultation
earlier this year looking at removing
and the Public Works loan board as a
source of funds for yielding activities
and such as property investments and
this consultation closes on the 31st of
July at 2020 and a response will be
submitted to the consultation but as yet
there is no tearing table and publish
for any proposed changes that are
proposed within that consultation and
the consultation is also looks forward
it isn't retrospective so any changes
that do come in into play
following the consultation won't reflect
properties already purchased or loans
already taken out and should to be a
change in peterborough B as being
proposed an alternative funding sources
will be investigated to an
people Tsukiko to continue trading so
I'm in conclusion the the business plan
as Chris mentioned earlier it's a really
important part of the company's
governance and provides a framework for
the future investment acquisitions
moving forward it also provides key
performance indicators which are really
important to be able to monitor the
performance of the company against those
indicators the portfolio as stands is is
a balanced portfolio with risk
diversified across sectors locations and
tenants and this really is very key to
the investment strategy there is a focus
on core assets and particularly and
cific alene to focus on the industrial
sector and refocus away from high street
retail where there are structural
changes occurring currently the board
recognizes the cove at 19 challenges and
and in many ways the these are mitigated
by that and balanced and diversified
portfolio whereby and there is no one
tenant or property or location that is
so weighty that it it has a significant
impact on on the portfolio as a whole so
the investment strategy has set out
earlier excuse me it's not significantly
changed from the previous year and it is
about particular emphasis on the
covenant strengths at this point in time
but largely it is about continuing to
build a diverse portfolio and mitigate
the risks by doing so and as finally
Cisco capital continues to provide
councils with an important income stream
and that is probably never more so
important than the current
thank you sorry I think cosmic roll may
have a couple problems with his mic at
the moment just bear with us for a
minute
so counsel McCraw dropped off the
meeting he's just rejoining now um and I
could see he's back let's see if he has
any luck getting the mic to work
No
so look
councilman crow can you hear us
right we're just going to see if we can
get somebody to help cosmic raw
right we might need to take an
adjournment for about five minutes to
see if we can get council McCraw back to
join us if we take it to quarter past
ten and hopefully we'll be back then
thank you
you
just making sure we live streaming okay
first of all apologies to members of the
public and obviously to people attending
the meeting itself for technical
difficulties we have quite a lot of
attendees for this meeting having heard
the chair of Cisco and the assistant
director Emily make their presentation
has now come to the time for members
questions now at this point I should
state we have received a large number of
questions and some of them may in fact
be repeating themselves to some extent
what I would ask is that if members have
questions that have already been
substantially asked answered in a
previous answer if they could either a
draw or alter their question to take
account of that just so that we don't
end up repeating ourselves over and over
again so once again we'll ask members in
alphabetical order for their questions
it may be that they have several we will
do that that way and there will be
further opportunity for questions after
that so start off with councillor Carter
that's certainly why affirm several
questions I hope I can ask it's once an
indicator in later the first being on
third part of that the background noise
the first one being on point for point
one I realized what was explained about
40 percent of these portfolios in the
East with others pretty near I'm
assuming big pretty near means to be
Milton Keynes ones which are embedded
here and not in the 80s we understand
that some steamapps were Quakers made on
point four point eight their questions
four counts in the Matteson system is
misophobia
we seem to have gone into the officer
sector as lost faith virtue to
homeworking rather into loss and then
sorry
sorry can you hear me I can now
okay I just let my daughter who's
wanting to shout me V we seem to Pontiff
your office sector as far as lost favor
due to my home working rather as we've
walked High Street as that went into
decline our properties attractively
priced because other side by divestment
and we at that point I wanted a glass
I do realize that's at the moment due to
the hot desking being with codes we are
having same out office space for less
matter work that workers going in how is
that going to be affected once the decay
that has been over with personal purpose
the burst but home working is still
going to be for preference so are we
going to be losing anything in that port
oh right
or say on point four point eight when
are we going to be investing in
renewable energy and I do believe that I
did have four more questions but at the
moment I cannot remember because I don't
I've got sir
slight interference of my own so do a
podcast about okay know quite a lot in
there
I don't know Chris and Emily would like
to take those questions or if there are
other members of the board who would be
best placed in certain areas thank you
and Chris I was going to suggest that
Nigel and Neville answer the questions
in relation to thee and the market
particularly in relation to and the
office sector and the geographical and
components of the portfolio and just a
point in terms of the renewable energy
opportunities and we have
I think we've only had one opportunity
presented to us in this sector to date
so it is a sector that we are interested
in but obviously we need those
opportunities to come forward and once
they come forward we will obviously
consider them and if they meet the
criteria they will be taken forward but
to date I think we've only had one quite
one renewable energy energy opportunity
come forward and it unfortunately didn't
meet the criteria Stephanie was on that
heavenly as well that I mean that the
that market is a new market and
obviously we are there for that that
leaves a degree of uncertainty and so
therefore we're probably not the right
sort of investor to be first into that
market but as it becomes more
established is certainly something which
we'll be looking at thanks Chris
so I'm Neville Nigel could you and
answer the questions in relation to the
office sector and also a geographical
makeup of the portfolio yes it's not
your goal to speaking up I'll start and
that's my colleague never pictured I'll
just talk through what we've actually
seen during Kovach 19 in terms of firm
capital investment activity it is a fair
question it's a question we get asked
and rather lot actually and what we have
seen from it is very little evidence at
this point they don't going to change
materially that and the reason we say
that is because a lot of lots of office
occupiers are just re-evaluating and how
they use their space rather than whether
they require or don't require it and so
we can see the trend which has already
started precoded of lowering density now
of occupational space within offices
since still allowing the lines and lines
of people lined up next to each other we
think that this can be a greater
diversification in the use of office
space and this was something it was
already starting to happen and there's a
lot more leisure based activity coming
into the work
environment by that I mean gyms cafes
and central areas for creativity and
communication and we think we can't see
more of them that actually takes up more
office space ahead than the desk base so
we we remain of the view that actually
we don't think it's meant material in
your sector and we also think a lot of
them headquarter companies I can look
very carefully at their spread of risk
um instead of being all in one building
which was the trend an urbanization
trend that we teamed for several years
and we do think now that we may see more
of an HQ and in a hub situation and
therefore we think that the regional
office sector market and may well
actually see the opposite happen and you
may well see more regional offices built
and occupied and the nerve voice would
have been previously um it's also fair
to add that since 2008 2009 we've seen
an awful lot of office stock disappear
from the market and there's actually
quite a low level of development in that
sector
so the overexposure of office space in
terms of surplus and is quite low and
vacancy rates now hitting historically
low levels for office base so we don't
actually see a tremendous difference and
change at this time other than how
companies utilized that space that they
have and know if you were able to offer
an here I think you know we have to look
at what we get out of office space and
you know wellthanks of teams calls are
actually quite good then we all know the
shortcomings and people dropping out and
the difficulty of getting the right
environment and everything else that
goes with that it was just not the same
as looking somebody in the eye or
shaking the hand and having those sort
of personal meetings so I think it's
very difficult to replace the office
with home working as nigel says that the
use of an office has changed we've seen
a lot of movement towards hot-desking
and in our offices then
there is effectively workstations for
only 70% of the staff on the basis that
people are asking or working from home
from time to time and that's not unusual
at all but what we have seen is a
greater increase in the areas for
meeting rooms for you know coffee you
know lots of seifer's and this sort of
thing
and that's because to attract the best
staff that officers have to provide an
environment which is attractive and
which has the benefits of a nice place
to work so in terms of the office space
we've seen very different uses of it
recently and instead of the
intensification of hot-desking
the one thing that coded may bring is
actually a greater desire for personal
space both in terms of elbow room and
also in terms of having your own desk so
it'll be interesting to see how that
works out going forward but the one
impact I think we're slightly nervous of
in the office sector is that of the
serviced offices the sort of reaches
type operation just because going
forwards a lot of people all thrown into
a mix of people completely unrelated
with what they're doing at comparatively
high costs per desk slightly nervous
that those may suffer from home working
because the question for those people is
what they're getting in addition to be
able to work from home in their own
environment which isn't so different
because they're not having that mix of
people around the greater social aspect
perhaps because it's a mix of other
different occupiers so the home working
thing has become much more intense over
the vic ovid period but i think in many
ways we've discovered the shortcomings
of that and as nigel says the overall
supply of office accommodation is very
low at the moment and what we are seeing
is rents are growing recently the one we
acquired in epson
the prevailing rents there were between
14 and 18 pounds a square foot and we've
just got a renewal there at 21 pounds of
square foot so we can bring the income
up the demand is there and you know what
we're trying to do is is driving
construed which is what we're saving to
just on the two other questions which
are raised actually if I come to Barry's
and Nigel I want to add some points
those as well as regards the the
regional bias I think the first thing to
say is the regional bias is indeed that
it's a bias it's not it's not an iron
ring put around the eastern region
clearly what we're aiming to do is
achieve a very robust portfolio in terms
of balance in terms of quality of income
and in terms of quality of location and
whilst something's beautiful place then
many of the centres are quite small
commercial centres and we do need to
focus on the intrinsic underlying demand
and value of assets because if it's a
local interest that doesn't necessarily
mean to say it's of interest to the
investment market as a whole they have
to be good strong commercial centers and
that's what we tried to focus on
certainly we have no desire to focus on
anything in the lights of Scotland or
Wales or the Northeast necessarily but
for the likes of Milton Keynes which is
great growth location we will win in
Lincoln which is not too far outside and
some of the assets we've bought have
been much more 2 and 25 focused because
that's a good underlying center where
the growth going forward and the
commercial investor demand is is very
strong and the number of opportunities
which are available are very limited by
the time we've refined them down to
those which meet the criteria then
there's obviously even fewer and then
when we decided that something is good
enough that we want to bid on it then
again that's even fewer and the ones
that we actually win or even pure still
and of the good news is we don't win
everything that we bid on but
if we did we'd have cause to worry that
we're paying too much but you know they
are competitive situations quite
frequently and we went some we lose
something that's just the nature of the
market the I mean it's worth just making
sure the committee is aware of the
figures I think we looked over the
period we looked at about 65
opportunities we bid on 16 and we were
successful on two so I think that
indicates you know the sort of the care
that is taken over the assets to be
acquired
it's alright matching and there were
some comment earlier on the renewables
and we rarely see renewable or assets
with an environmental aspect to them the
the one we did find was a property in
the Harvard share but we ruled that out
on two counts personally the strength of
the tenant was quite weak and so there's
no guarantee they wouldn't go bust and
secondly the income stream was based on
the turnover as to the amount of energy
that was being generated and there was
no way that one could control that and
so the turnover may have gone down or up
and so there was no guarantee what
income would come out of that as opposed
to situation where you have a lease and
you can actually predict what the course
Lincoln will be okay gab councillor
Carter has that addressed the most of
your question is there it has addressed
the questions I have also remembered the
other ones I had it would have be
possible if I ask them or would you want
to move perhaps we should move on and
come back to those at the end of the
members questions where we can assemble
things from there and of course they may
be covered by somebody else councillor
Caston any questions thank you
very much chair can you hear me yes yes
so a question regarding the current
balance of 83% core and 17% called Plus
is the amount of asset within that core
criteria a risk it which would be the
risk of being so heavily invested in
court in a rapidly changing market is
there it is
is that they are we investing where the
market has been in currently is instead
of looking at where the market is going
by not speculating so far and not being
invested so much in core plus saying
we're not are we being too safe well I
think it's um I think it's quite
important for risk management not to be
completely safe absolutely I imagine
because you'll miss the market as it
moves on but okay can we and can we keep
answers as brief as is possible that
actually answer the question because we
do have a rather large number of
questions I've just like to point that
out who'd like to take press I've just
come in on that thing and quickly I mean
we have certainly tried to find slightly
more risky assets but what you've got to
look at and is what is the pricing of
those assets because the market has been
relatively hot over the last two years
what we found is that actually the more
risky assets the pricing is also on
those has been pretty hot too and what
you get is yield that the secondary
assets is what we call those to the
secondary assets the yields tend to come
down closer to prime assess the prime
assets of course have got very very
strong fundamentals they make for a very
good solid portfolio a secure income and
we are certainly still looking now for
the more secondary assets which have a
greater yield and hopefully and there is
a possibility of course that the the
current pandemic may give us some
opportunity to find those but at the
moment we have male to find them at the
price that we wanted to pay okay that
satisfy a counselor question
yes thank you to effective counsel at
Gould have you any questions yes I have
firm Thank You chair I think just as a
comment to councilor customs question I
would just like to say that the areas
that have been invested in that and have
been traditionally safe may not be safe
anymore
so what we consider might be too safe in
reality with covert or actually
potentially moving to the more risky
areas and I'll just throw that in as a
comment very in terms of the green
question I just wonder whether there's
any mileage in looking actually looking
a little bit more deeply for green
projects to invest in rather than I
think my question would be do we wait
for them to cross our paths or are we
looking for them in a slightly more
proactive way and then I've got some
questions that have been given to me by
some of the members I think if I could
just read some of those one is page 47
the pie chart refers to invest year a
chunk of money in the food and beverage
metered including Dryden's I think I
would just like to ask how that squares
with the statement on page 43 the
environmental implications which states
that there is no known environmental
impacts from the new business plan and
that both councils have actually
declared a climate emergency and are
keen to improve the sustainability of
their portfolios and so how does the
that sort of chunk of money in food and
beverages square with that merely just
another question please the receive a
copy of the folio financial accounts are
sift are going to continue this is
another question to invest despite the
threat of a recession and if so what are
you planning to invest into and I just
noticed that they the PW lb consultation
that you said you'd be looking at
alternative
and I'm just wondering what that
alternative country might be I think
probably that's all I've got at the
moment Thank You mr. chair I should like
come in on on that on those points and
so I think probably your question in
relation to green projects and in
relation to to the potential
drive-through as a small proportion of
investments and so the board of Cisco
are and aware that the shareholding
councils have prepared the climate
emergency and are keen to address
sustainability within the portfolio we
are currently drafting a sustainability
policy for the company and with the
assistance of Jones Langer sorry hmm
excuse me my fund managers and
acquisition agents so that is something
that we do and are putting some some
real effort and focus into so I think
the other point should be that and it
isn't just about the assets that we
acquire but it's also about how we
manage the portfolio and how we support
tenants to make the right decisions
about sustainability moving forward so
for example it may be that we have
tenants who are looking to undertake
some alterations to their premises and
in that case we would certainly be
encouraging them to look at other
sustainable excuse me technologies
moving forward so there is a commitment
from Cisco to help to address the
climate change emergency that that has
been declared and in respect to the
full-year accounts the the accounts will
be published when they're finalized as
they are every year we anticipate this
will be at some point and throughout the
summer they're normally published with
companies housed in either late July or
August
and so so that's answer to that question
and the question in relation to the
recession I might refer on to on to
Neville as you know a market expert in
that area but just in terms of the and
pwlp funding and you ask the question in
relation to alternative funding types
now at this point in time the council
uses a range of borrowings it isn't all
just P wlb and borrowing at this point
in fact within the report you can see
that there is short and long term
borrowings the long-term borrowing tends
to be P WL be short term is is other
sources which may be other local
authorities and lending to each other
and so there are a range of different
funding types it is also still
relatively early days in terms of
looking at alternative funding types but
I know some other authorities have
looked at municipal bonds for instance
so there are certainly will be a range
of alternative options within the p WL b
consultation and it does say that if
local authorities wish to buy
investments primary primarily for yield
they will remain free to do so and but
they won't be able to use p WL b and
within the year that they've bought the
assets so just to sort of clarify that
point and never did you want to pick up
the point about investing in commercial
property at times such as this yes
firstly we're not sure what is down the
road we know that an awful lot of
difficulty will come out of the wash
over the course of the next six to nine
months as furloughing
is no longer the case and there will
inevitably be some redundancies in
various companies and some companies
will struggle to keep afloat the degree
of that is very difficult
to estimate we have had varying input
from the likes of Oxford Economics and
our in research teams it is anticipated
that you know the next 12 to 18 months
will be difficult thereafter there are
all sorts of letters you can subscribe
to whether it's a u-shaped or a v-shaped
or a w-shaped or the J shape door or you
name it in terms of which way the
economy is going to go what we can say
is that over the course of the last even
2-3 weeks we are seeing quite a
resurgence in the investment market a
lot of people starting to engage again
from a situation where the majority of
transactions were actually frozen and
that has been particularly strong in the
food sectors and the distribution
sectors but also offices are picking up
fairly swiftly obviously retailers is
proving sticky for a moment but it's
interesting to see how quickly the stock
markets recovered there certainly seems
to be some belief there that some things
will not be all bad but the fundamentals
I think are that we still come back to
the outlier there that the key features
of the Cisco requirements which is to
have a balanced portfolio and have
ideally long term income streams from
good quality talents and what we are
finding is the market is very much
driven towards there's more core
properties and the lower risk properties
and actually that's probably where we
should be as well the Australia for our
purposes in driving a long term quality
income stream but also because that is
where the strength of the market is and
the underlying value going forwards
whether is least risk and it will see us
through what may be a sticky few years
but we'll maintain an income stream
which is real on okaythat's
councillor Gold's questions is that I'm
sufficient for your answering the moment
Castle gold
yes I think so I think there's just
maybe something else around an exit plan
if losses continue to and default
considerably because I mean these are
uncharted financial times aren't they
and global recession being on the
horizon and so what what is the exit
plan and I appreciate that yes times are
hard we all know that in times of light
coming under God and keeping an eye on
things is good but but presumably that
there are going to be some exit plans
and presumably there is that there is a
flaw at which we say we've lost a lot
and we need to kick in to actually exit
plans
thank you I mean an exit plan would be
seemed to me I don't know I'm just
saying would seem a little de alien to
the very concept of Cisco but I don't
know if anybody can so that question and
so the the fund has been set up for
income and it is continuing to deliver
income the losses that have been
incurred have been and book losses so
they relate to the fluctuations in in
value so in reality those losses will
only be realized if those assets are to
be sold and so there is no formal exit
strategy for Cisco as a whole now
obviously part of the job of the board
is to manage the fund and at some point
in in the future there may be
opportunities where different assets
could be considered for sales but that
would be and because that's the right
thing for the fund in terms of whether
those assets may have increased in value
or whether we see them no longer being
in a position to provide the level of
income that we wish to obtain but
certainly at this point in time income
still continues to be delivered and is
still we're still seeing growth in
income and albeit we're seeing those
capital values fluctuate in accordance
with the market priming it is really
important to say that those capital and
capital values over the long term you
turn
to see property values have tended to
increase even when you've had
fluctuations during recessionary times
but the important thing for this fund is
that it is income delivering okay Thank
You councillor Grandin do you have your
questions as at your hand as it were
yes Thank You chair um my question from
myself has already been answered
regarding the office sector so thank you
very much that was very helpful I have
got two questions from residents Hadley
residents and they have not in total so
I will ask those questions if I may
question 1 from the Hadley resident is
what does the board of Cisco estimate
the total write down known as
impairments in the accounts that will be
shown in the Cisco statutory accounts to
31st March 2020 and he's referring to
also the situation going forward saying
that we have failed to collect around
30% of the rain to date and so he
foresees things being more difficult
going forward so he'd like an answer on
that
the second question has partly being
answered but if I may ask it anyway and
then you can tell me why are over 40% of
the properties purchased to date by
Cisco not in the state akia graphical
error targeted for acquisition in the
East of England why were the Cisco Board
unable to find enough suitable
investment properties in East Anglia
using East Anglia rate payers money okay
just question here Emily
observation they are not actually using
ratepayers money am i correct and so we
are borrowing funds for Cisco so and
we've talked about this already so the
funds are either PW lb or other known
sources I think a point that probably
should be made is that the income that
is generated from Cisco so we've talked
about and the last financial year one
point six three three million being the
net income into the councils that's
money that effectively comes from
properties that may be outside of our
districts but that money is then brought
into our districts and can be spent
within our districts so the income
that's generated from those capital
value purchases outside of our district
is actually being reinvested within our
districts and so I think that's a sort
of point of clarity in that regard um in
terms of the impairments and that that
figure is the three and a half million
pounds that was mentioned in the
presentation and is in the report and as
I mentioned that's made up of
approximately half a million pounds
worth of costs of acquisitions and we
expect until the acquisition fund is
completed that there will continue to be
an impairment in the annual accounts
that relate to cost of acquisition until
the acquisition program has completed
and then the adjustment and valuation
that we've talked about which is the
three point roughly 3.1 million so we're
anticipating that those impairments will
be in the order of three and a half
million pounds which is the the loss
that that Cisco is predicting for that
financial year and I I think in terms of
the question relating to why are there
only forty percent or wire forty percent
of the assets outside of the eastern
region I think we have addressed that
question and it is about the nature of
opportunities that
come forward and the importance of
investing in the sort of strong capital
markets and to be able to deliver that
income return to the company and to the
councils and another point I just
thought I'd throw this in here of course
in some cases you're in competition with
other possible purchasers who may in
fact be prepared to pay a higher price
than citko are and you may find that
that does not provide the return that is
actually be built into the system the
requirement to make five point seven
five or six point four one percent
somewhere around that figure in order to
service the debt am I correct
and whenever we're looking to acquire
assets we're always in competition and
with with other investors and yes and
those investors may have a different
criteria and as a consequence may be
prepared to pay more for an asset than
we may be okay and that's indicated as
well by the numbers said earlier no
we've looked at 65 assets over the year
Don 16 and we've acquired two and it's a
matter of getting things at what we
think is the right price yeah we clearly
have a difficulty and I think in some
ways because obviously people are
looking for safety but at the same time
they're also looking for opportunity and
it's a very fine balance can we turn now
to councillor adding them for if you
have any questions counselor counselor
having him all I can come back to
council heading over here
if she can't hear me at the moment
councillor McLaren so alistair terence
covered that so i'm happy
Thank You councillor McLaren any
questions okay we shall move back at the
need to councillor Muller Thank You
chair actually just just one question we
successfully collected over 70% of the
rental income to you in the March
quarter do we have any idea of the
percentage we'd like you to claim in the
June quarter which off the ends this
week place
and so working with an Jones Lang
LaSalle and our portfolio managers we're
estimating and somewhere in the region
of 45 to 50 percent but you'll
appreciate you know this is very
uncertain time so that was looking at
the nature of our businesses and our
tenants and who were most impacted by
the jacobian situation now and their
ability to trade effectively and things
are changing almost on a daily basis in
that that's based and a number of those
businesses are expected to while some of
the you know retailers have started to
trade already a number of other
businesses have started expected to
start trading within the next few weeks
so that's the sort of broad area that
we're anticipating at the current point
and just to clarify that in March we
collected over 70% of the rents and if
Co were able to make the Foldit
repayment to the council as a
consequence of their sort of cash flow
management and we are hoping that Cisco
will be in a position to make a greater
debt repayment than the the rent
collected in the June quarter I think
the other point to be made is that the
rent as per Chris's slide earlier on in
the presentation showed that that rent
is deferred and so we are expecting that
rent to be received it's effectively
just being repro filed so we're
receiving us at a different time to when
we would originally have expected to
incur and that that income and I think
it's important to say that that's part
of the responsibles on a landlord-tenant
relationship you know working with our
tenants as partners in this to make sure
that they get through it and that it
works through a very difficult time
Castle McLaren did you have anything
else you wanted actually I'm sorry check
can you hear me
yes we can outright I trouble with my
mute that's okay we we've had this
before her segment so just bear with me
so thank you chair and I've got two
questions the other questions have
actually been very well answered by the
team but the one looking at financial
predictions the main impact of Kovach 19
for councils and everybody will be the
year 2021 to 22 what is already planned
by Cisco to reevaluate and individual
investments in the portfolio in the
light of what may occur sort of 80
months ahead and how that would impact
the council and the second question I've
got if you look at financial reports as
a lot of mentions about the section one
five one officer and I'm wondering what
the relationship is with our sexual one
five one officer I think it's in the
room and an Cisco as a an independent
enterprise Thank You chair thank you
okay who would like to address those
points um well I'm conscious Katherine
is in the room and and had some nother
meeting at 11:00 so where the Katherine
wants to step in at this point to
explain her relationship and with Cisco
yeah yeah I can do that
as you know Cisco is an independent
company has its own accounts and they're
published on on obviously company's
house but mid Suffolk is the 100 percent
shareholder of that from and from vapor
image suffix perspective so what's
important for Baber in mid Suffolk is
the income that comes back into the
councils and as Emily and others have
been saying
that there's deferment of that at the
moment rather than on collection if we
were sort of really worried that there
was gonna be long-term defaults by Cisco
in terms of being able to make their
loan repayments then the councils would
need to have conversation with Cisco
about it being a going concern at the
moment I haven't got any section one
month all worries if you like in terms
of Cisco because we are talking about
deferment of income rather than non
collection on a permanent basis so it's
just a timing and more of a cash flow
issue so so that's probably how I'd
summarize it at the moment in terms of
my thinking between the relationship can
I take can I take the opportunity here
and I why we we have Katherine with us
because I think my question relates to
that function as well and I noticed some
MCS I should be about here we will come
back to the rest of your questions
councillor McLaren but on the subject of
our break-even point because we are
after all receiving an income around the
6 percent level paying off a loan
basically servicing our debt and the
difference is the income generated for
the two councils now the treasury
management structure obviously is where
Katherine comes in what I'm asking is is
what is how bad would things have to be
for us not to be able to service that
debt what sort of percentage of rent
arrears would we be in or what
percentage of rents would remain
uncollected before we were in a position
where we were actually losing or not
receiving the enough money to service
the debt and I think that's quite a key
point I mean how far away is that I
think it must be fairly distant but I
would like some some nerves and words on
that Kathy oh yeah we don't get to
figures I was because I've got in front
of me as well so I'm happy to answer
that yet we have looked at what the
position is in terms of the position of
Brett back break-even and as you're
aware from
previous answers to questions the
position is different for the two
councils so for mid Suffolk because the
borrowing costs are higher the
break-even point is 40% a collection of
rent and for Baber
it's 29% so Weber has got more Headroom
in terms if you like that break-even
point because of the lower borrowing
costs so present and at that point we
have secured tenancies we have long
lasting covenants and we've already made
arrangements to address this in the
future by deferring rents for short
periods of time so we're a long way I'd
make my observation only we seem to be a
long way from anywhere getting anywhere
near that break-even point even in the
worst case scenario and I'd suggest if
it ever got to that stage I think we'd
be worrying about a great deal more than
just Cisco anyway let's move back to
Catholic on how I think you've still got
questions two remaining unanswered yes
sorry there is a question about
reevaluating yes and so just from the
board's perspective we evaluate assets
on a quarterly basis that's part of the
review process that that we have with
our fund managers so we look at assets
on a quarterly basis and they are
revalued annually so all of the assets
are valued on the 31st of March in every
financial year and so that evaluation
process is it's very much part of the
and the board's function and I'm not
quite sure what your query then was and
and how that will impact the council so
I think it empowerment with the other
side is we do have a a timeline of key
events whether those are event reviews
or leases coming - and all that sort of
thing that we have a timeline of key
events looking at that over the life of
them of the the assets so that again is
as Emily quite rightly says is it
evaluated quarterly just to make sure to
see what's coming up what revenues
coming up
there may be a lot of rent renewal or
leases this is coming to an end of bread
clauses so it's all part of the
evaluation of the assets looking forward
and so then in terms of the impact on
the council tsypko is obviously looking
at its income and projecting it's its
income forward and the council obviously
has its budgets as well and which look
at the income that is already generated
by the fund that has been built up and
Buddha's or also looks at the income
that will be generated from the further
tranche of the investment so there's
approximately 40 million that is and has
been approved or was approved last year
so the budget or budgets currently
anticipate that investment being being
made and does that help to answer your
query in that regard
Thank You Emily I think it's unless well
it was answered by by Catherine to be
honest that concern ad so thank you very
much thank you
Thank You counsel McLaren councillor
Muller I think we did address your
questions but I'm just checking that I
haven't missed you out know you we we've
answer Emily's Carney answer my question
Thank You councillor Osborne any
questions from you cancel spawn your mic
is unmute all right we can move on and
come back to Council Osborn councillor
scarf thank you yeah well I mean coming
near the end a lot of the questions who
already been asked and hired questions
about the Public Works loan board and
the alternative sources of funding and
the the last one was just the property
re-evaluation so no questions at the
moment thank you thank you very much
councillor Willem
thank you check am I being heard you are
um thank you can can I just follow up
your question chair about the collection
of rent and have I misunderstood this or
you see
that if the correction of the rent goes
down to 40% she's I think what Katherine
said was like break-even point that
would service the Miss Suffolk Marui and
give no income for which which Miss
Suffolk could use for and supporting
their services I think that's I'm pretty
certain that's what Katherine said there
yeah so so in relation to mid Suffolk it
was 40% in relating to Baber I think
customers there 29% and so that would
effectively mean that and there would be
the debt would be covered and but it
would be the net income that would be
deferred for the council's and obviously
that deferment means that that income
would be received so it's more about
when it's received rather than if it's
received but that would be an extremely
well extreme case I appreciate that um
Emily in your slides well you showed
that there's a 5.6 6% downward
adjustment of 3.1 million I assume
that's over the year yes that's right so
that's the difference in the capital
valuation and in March this year to
March last year so the loss paper loss
over the over the year was 3.5 million
and do we know what the total loss is
since since if ago was set up and what
the predicted lost for 2021 might be and
do we know when the losses might cease
they the losses last year that were
published with 3.1 million and and that
was made up of approximately one and a
half million pounds of costs of
acquisition and one and a half million
pounds of valuation adjustment which was
primarily in relation to the retail
assets within the fund and in terms of
predicting forward I would anticipate
that there will be further costs that
will need to be impaired against until
such point as
completed the investment program so as I
mentioned before the costs of acquiring
assets tends to be in the order of six
and three-quarter percent so that covers
stamp duty professional fees etc so
those are the the costs of acquiring
assets and until we stop acquiring
assets we will be making those and
losses or impairments in effect and with
regard to and the evaluation of the
portfolio and that is market dependent
and it is difficult at any time to
forecast values into the future in fact
as a member of the our ICS I'm actively
encouraged not to forecast values in
into the future but particularly at this
point in in time it's very difficult to
forecast what values will be like this
time next year and because the market is
so uncertain and but certainly we do
anticipate losses to be made in relation
to the costs of acquisition until that
that period ceases and we're expecting
the acquisition period to continue until
October 21 thank you um we're here to
scrutinize a business plan so to help
you with that
I've got a couple of fairly basic
questions I need to know a bit more
about the flow of funds from the
councils to Cisco and the flow of funds
from Cisco to the councils so when a
purchase is made is it with a hundred
percent loan or do the council's loan
the majority of that and hold a small
equity stake and so the Cisco is set up
on the basis of a 90 percent loan and
ten percent equity so each council holds
five percent equity and so as with the
fluctuations in the portfolio value
obviously the equity value fluctuates as
well because it's a proportion of the
the property values it that they fund
just wanted to clarify something because
the holding company would that be a
separate
corporate structure and the separate
equity and no it's in effect it's the
same equity it just flows through the
company so it's it's and there aren't
too lots of 10% it's the same 10% so in
effect the holding company owns the 10%
but the shareholders only holding
companies so that it's the same 10% or
5% per council my apologies gala welcome
thank you sir yeah so following from
that so the the the council's are put in
some equity every time there's a
purchase there's equity but as there's
been a revaluing downwards presumably
the equity that the council's have has
also reduced do we know by how much and
so the so yes as I said so that equity
and will fluctuate in value as the
portfolio does but again it's not it's
it's ten percent of the portfolio
effectively so shared between the two so
whatever that portfolio fluctuation is
that's the equity so it's not in
addition to Cisco losses it's the same
SIF Colossus just recorded in and it
gets consolidated up into the accounts I
think Kathryn isn't with us anymore
otherwise she might be better at
explaining that and but the holding
company figures or accounts will be
published later this year as well along
with the council's
accounts and those details are always
included within the council's accounts
and the holding company's accounts in
terms of the actual numbers or figures
so sorry I made I maybe even think so if
over three years cisco makes losses of
around three million so it totals to ten
million at the end of three years and
the council's hold between them one
ninth
oh the money that's put in does that
mean that the council's equity has has
dropped by 1/9
the council's equity will reduce aligned
with the value of the portfolio so
equally should the value of the
portfolio increase then the equity will
increase as well so the equity will
fluctuate and in a in the in an aligned
way effectively
yeah that's thank you yeah that that's
clarified it so to don't do we know what
the equity is at present and so the
accounts are currently being prepared
and at the moment so I haven't got those
figures
immediately to hand and but as I as I
mentioned the the equity amount is
published and within our accounts and
within the council's accounts so those
figures will become available and once
those accounts are are published thank
you
so we've we've heard that if the
collection goes down to 40% which is
unlikely to who could service the
borrowing that Midsomer parva there'd be
no income so I think that my next
question this is a risk is it a risk
that ought to be in the risk table in
the business plan so the risk table is
within the accommodate accompanying
report and that's the significant risk
register for the council and rather than
and a sort of operational risk register
but that risk effectively says that
there's a risk if Cisco fails to meet
its income returns or it's or its return
so I think it is reflected in that risk
it's a but it's possibly phrased in a
more generic way rather than in a
detailed and
away right now so obviously we go
through a difficult with difficult
period particularly for Wagamama and
Costa and gyms and car showrooms and so
on so because of that is it reasonable
for Cisco to set the same KPIs as in
previous years so and I think the board
of Cisco wanted to maintain some
[Music]
consistency in KPI so that you can also
the councils can continue to measure us
against those KPIs rather than and us
amending those too greatly I suppose in
Cisco's favor so we want to continue to
have and those those sort of
aspirational KPIs rather than reducing
them down so you can measure our
performance more consistently and over
over a longer term and within the
business plan we do say that we expect
KPI 4 which is in relation to rent
arrears to be challenging and for us to
meet and that we would like to keep that
KPI so that's our aspiration in the sort
of longer term as we get through and
these more sort of difficult over 19
times so you think they're realistic
over the four year and that wasn't quite
what I said I think what I said is we
want to keep them consistent so you can
measure our performance against them but
particularly in relation to KPI for that
is going to be difficult for us to
achieve and because of the Cove in 1950
raised in the fullness of time and so
we'd like to keep that KPI consistent
but we are putting our hands up now and
saying we think that is going to be
difficult for us to achieve and well as
far as for debate but whether whether or
not lemons feel comfortable with you
having the a consistent target rather
than perhaps a more realistic target but
that's a matter for debate
many businesses included in their
business plans a reduction plan or a
winding down plan now we understand
obviously that Cisco is the investments
are for a very long term but wouldn't it
be reasonable to ask that the business
plan should be able to cover the
eventualities of one or more of the
council's needing to release some equity
from Cisco is that covered in any degree
of detail and so the makeup of the
company structure and is governed
effectively by the articles of the
company's operation the articles of the
holding company's operations and most
specifically by the equity subscription
agreement between the two councils as
they both have an interest in in in
Cisco and so there is an equity
subscription agreement between the
council's and that would look at
effectively if the council's wanted to
change their current arrangements the
equity subscription would help to govern
how that would be dealt with moving
forward so is that available somewhere
either for members to look at - and to
understand or even the public that's
part of the companies and governance it
isn't a public document it is a document
that is for the holding companies and so
it would be for the holding companies to
determine whether they wanted to share
that document more widely thank you I
think it's important to point out that
obviously when it comes to governance
issues that scrutiny have in the past
looked at the governance arrangements
relating to the holding companies and to
Cisco itself and here obviously we're
dealing with last year's report next
year's business plan just to just draw
that distinction oh absolutely
and in Section 6.2 of the report is
stated that the income generated through
Cisco supports the investment
in other key projects and it quotes
gateway 14 now my understanding is that
gateway 14 their development of gateway
14 is funded wholly by borrowing from
the Public Works loan board is it not so
I'm not can you show me where there's a
direct link between the income from
Cisco and gateway 14 so the report
states that it being from Cisco helps
other projects within the council and I
think it says such as gateway 14 so the
gateway 14 and cific over both property
projects in effect and they have a
different risk profile so gateway 14 is
a development company and with no income
in the short term it is expenditure so
the balance between Cisco which is an
income generating company and gateway 14
and means that Cisco can provide cash
flow and income into the council in the
short medium and long term against
gateway 14 which is a development
company which isn't generating income in
the short term but will develop income
and capital receipts in the longer term
so there's a balance between those
activities and excuse me there is also
obviously one executive team that serves
both gateway 14 and Cisco and as such
there are costs that are associated with
with those with that team and obviously
the income that's generated from Cisco
could be used towards that revenue cost
of and supporting that team but
obviously that's a you know it income
comes in to the council and can be used
for any number of different and revenue
costs and it isn't allocated you know
and this money is collected and paid
against why but
is obviously income it comes in to the
council and does help to support the
services that the council delivers which
includes and the executive that I'm part
of that helps to manage both gateway 14
and Cisco and gateway 14 and unsafe
copay for that and by way of recharges
to and from the council to those
companies yes so there is that there is
a tenuous link but gateway 14 the
development of gateway 14 would be
possible would have been possible if we
didn't have not had Cisco 14 no and I
don't think in the report I'm suggesting
that it couldn't go ahead without no I'm
just saying that obviously the income
and its generated from Cisco is is
immediate and provides cash flow to the
council which enables them to look at of
the projects that have a longer time
scale and for cash flow to be delivered
so sorry Alistair but that's true of any
projects that we're delivering and
through the council could it be seen
Emily as a counterbalance it's a gateway
40 it could be yes indeed I'm just
throwing that in question chair and then
I'm done I think look looking at the the
risk table there's no mention in there
no specific mention in there of company
losses and and we know that company
losses will continue and until at least
until the all the money spent so to
speak and do you not think that there
should be something in the risk register
about losses and potential future losses
sorry I was on mute and say the the risk
says the risk is the capital fund does
not generate the forecast investment
returns and so I think you know that can
be interpreted as both income and
capital it is a it's a broad risk and as
I'm
and it's it's part of the significant
risk register rather than and the
operational risk so it is about
consolidating that to a wider risk
element rather than the individual risks
thank you I think I'm asked all my
questions thank you very much can we
return to counselor Osborne who we
passed through last time if Casper
Osborne has any questions Thank You mr.
chair well first of all the presentation
has been excellent and the questions
that have been asked as sort of put a
lot of my mind at rest of them and the
answers in particular will well will
answered I haven't so I'm happy with the
questions that have been asked I haven't
any myself now as I've gone through that
I would like to make a comment that of
course our technical skills in in
crystal balls still needs to come
forward a lot I think for next year
thank you thank you very much so I mean
I think it's obviously a learning curve
for all of us at the moment although I
think one thing it does point out is
that face-to-face meetings are far
preferable there are subtleties that you
miss however now we've had questions
around from all those members does
anybody want to return to any questions
that they somehow omitted in the first
round in which case if there are no
further questions from members of the
committee and I hand if there are raise
your hand up sorry counselor Carter yes
so I do apologize for the track tonight
I just wanted to ask but the last two
questions but I had admitted previously
g2b interrupts in the background as
landlords are we responsible for the
environmental friendliness of our assets
the insulation etc I do believe it's a
governmental requirements if we are are
they up to stretch with the insulation
and if not how will getting for
buildings after standards affect our
portfolio financially how will
get in the properties of to establish
new protectors and also do you believe
at the introduction it's mentioned that
investing in social housing was an
interest market we're looking into if
that was a case it is is this buying new
properties or building the properties
and if such a sphere is building parties
as we have nasty climate mergency are we
looking at building cars a neutral
property supported by renewable energy
sources would that be seen under when
would you have that information and so
just in response to the question about
environmental responsibilities and
majority of our leases are full
repairing insuring which means that the
tenant has and the responsibility to
maintain the property and in in that
case any changes and that were required
whether that's from a choice perspective
or whether it's from a legislation
required changes they would be the
tenants responsibility and in the event
that the tenant was looking to undertake
any changes they would obviously need to
do that in accordance with building regs
and as a landlord we would encourage
them to make sure they make sustainable
choices and so we're not anticipating
any increase to in costs for those
repairs or adaptions and the majority of
properties that cific owned do have an
EPC rating of C or D which is a sort of
key point to consider and as obviously
you can't let properties that are f or g
ratings though cisco has in acquiring
its stock made sure that it does and
make sure it meets those sort of minimum
requirements i suppose
within that environment an environmental
perspective in terms of your second
question the introduction was talking
more broadly about the council's
activities rather than sift codes
activities so there is no intention for
Cisco to acquire any social housing or
to develop any social housing okay thank
you okay thank you very much councillor
now then unless and any members of the
committee have any other questions at
this point I'd like to ask if there are
any questions of clarity only from
members of the councils who are present
in this meeting and if councillor
Osborne and a couple of others I believe
Castle Rose born and yes Thank You mr.
chairman
then look the last question that counts
the cutter made surely comes under HRA
accounts and come out under a different
stream anyway so
and I thank Emily for the the reply
about the Cisco involvement so surely
that that is not part of any SIF go so
it's a different stream of funding for
from the council thank you thank you and
councillor Gould I see your hand raised
yes thank you
I just wanted to push it back a little
bit mr. chair please on the decision to
invest in drive-ins knowing that the
council's have declared a climate
emergency and I'm sure that the board
realizes the impact of emissions on
drive-throughs or I suppose drive
throughs on emissions really and I just
wondered how councillors can influence
investment strategy if we believe that
perhaps the board on following the
Council's wishes okay I mean effectively
from the point of view of the governance
side of things I would say that the
strategy and this is only looking at it
from the point of view of our overview
and scrutiny over all the business plan
is looked at by the council's all
together both separately and of course
we have representation on the boards of
the holding companies and
indeed on the board of Cisco itself so
if a resolution were to be passed in
council for a specific area I would
imagine that that would be the best
direction to raise such a point I'm not
sure we can do it through a scrutiny
function I don't know what other members
think about that I was just wondering
what the process was I don't think I was
suggested it I would say that from from
from my own understanding of the
situation it would probably be best
addressed through one our
representatives directly by speaking to
them and who by addressing it within the
council chamber in a full council
meeting now I believe this is scheduled
to come to council and that's a point
your point on drive-ins I believe we
have some questions coming in from
outside and I know our governance
officer Henry at Holloway has been
receiving some questions which she's
been frantically trying to draw my
attention to but we are operating with
multiple screens here and not all of
them are working Henriette do you have
anything for from us from any member of
the Council not at the moment I think
Council Lindsay did actually ask earlier
about the investing in Drive Thru which
in Council gules just raised a theta and
I think he wanted some clarity for that
and he didn't quite understand the point
as far as I can see that's all for now
thanks that's okay how's the gold if you
could take your hand down on the screen
that'd be helpful because we're about to
it's not it's not responding very well
is it gone now gone now but I've had the
same delay myself okay so we've more or
less covered all the questions I believe
we we wanted to ask if anybody has any
left speak now before we go into debate
so I will open the item up for debate
who would like to start
well that was don't all rush at once and
we've heard an awful lot on awful lot of
different ideas I think the question
really is is this balance between one we
want the council's position to be
protected and we want to be as safe as
possible in difficult times and the
other question is how do we do that and
still ensure that the income which is
welcome let's be honest however whatever
size it is any income to support our
services whatever each council chooses
to do with that money has to be a
welcome matter no matter what people
felt about the setting up of Sisko in
the start or even the concept of Sisko
it has produced an income and it looks
like it can continue to produce an
income the question is is the safety
factor high enough is it a risk that we
think is one we should worry about or
not so members please let's let's talk
about it councillor McCraw I think
councillor Caston then council scarf and
in council willem have their hands
raised at the moment thank you very much
I'm only getting one at a time
councillor Caston then thank you I just
like to say if if we're in to debate a
lot of the issues that the councillors
have brought up from the Renewable side
and the and how these buildings are run
are actually addressed in the climate by
the climate change task force and the
proposals they've put in and they've
been they've put forward proposals to
investigate that side of it to see what
we can do like low carbon tariffs and
looking at those buildings and how we
can help tenants to make them more
efficient but I think that might answer
a few of those questions that have been
and brought up throughout this meeting
thank you that's very helpful
councillor Willem
Thank You Jer I thought gets the
scuffles going first oh I apologize I
don't see his hand raised on here but
that may just be my screen I apologize
counselor SCAF um now I I want to return
to the to the the elements of risk
clearly this a report probably quite
similar to this report will be going to
council in a few weeks time and when it
does I would like to see more
information around risk and perhaps more
explanation of the equity I'm I had not
I had not understood at all until
yesterday I think it was or Saturday
that we had an equity share in all of
these properties and that that equity
was reducing and possibly will continue
to reduce and I think that should be
addressed in the report and and also I'm
not I try to understand the business
about almost it doesn't matter about the
losses but it to me it does and I think
that we need more more explanation
rather than just to say oh well there
will be losses and they may be around
three men in a year and they may
continue for another two years
but it's only a paper loss and I'm quite
a simple soul and I was like more
explanation of that and I would like to
see that in the risk in the risk
register ok Catholics cough thank you
Jeff
yeah well we've we've heard a lot about
the success in terms of collection of
rents and we've also heard about the
deferment of rents but my question would
be on my point would be how do we
actually know that the deferments of
rents that are proposed ie the shortfall
will actually eventually materialize we
have I would assume no guarantee that
they will eventually materialize if a
company's trading position weakens over
the next six nine months or whenever
they've had the deferment period for how
do we know that we're at
eventually going to get that money
because what it's a cash flow situation
I think there's a huge risk there and I
wonder what others think about that okay
and he thought from any members please
on that I mean I I'm conscious of it
again and I don't know that this is
entirely relevant or a direct parallel
but I'm very conscious of remembering in
the past when homeowners were facing a
amount of considerable negative equity
and obviously the biggest concern that
they had at the time was that they not
so much the negative equity itself but
they wouldn't be able to afford to pay
their mortgage I have a house I pay a
mortgage on it and frankly whether it
drops a few thousand pounds in value at
any time or a five percent in value
doesn't greatly concern me because I
intend to be here it's a long-term
project
twenty five year mortgages are quite
common sometimes longer these days I
don't worry greatly that its value might
diminish in the short pit term because
I'm going to be here for the long term
and I can only live in one house I know
others manage with more but I can only
live in one what I concern myself out
about is whether I can service the
mortgage the service the debt but in
this instance the servicing is actually
producing an income and it's as though I
was able to invest in my house and my
house was paying me back now that seems
to me to be a positive and maybe I'm
oversimplifying this but again if an
asset is not to be disposed of and
you've got no intention or no
requirement to dispose of it which is
why I worry when we talk about exit
strategies an exit strategy is the sort
of thing you talk about when you're
actually going to be looking to clear
the decks bail out and and abandon or
hope all you hope you what you enter
here effectively we are nowhere near
that if we've done the job properly and
if Cisco have done the job properly I
hope they demonstrated that they have
there is no necessity for that why would
you boss it possibly want to sell when
the market is is low you wouldn't I
think this is a obviously up
problem there's going to be a problem
for some time to come but even within
three months people have jumped to
conclusions that it's going to stay like
this or it's going to stay like that and
I don't think we have the data on which
to make those assumptions all we can do
is operate with due diligence I have
fewer fears than I might have done
before I'd read the report that that's
my thoughts anyway councillor Grandin
your hand is raised okay
we have lots of bleeping noises coming
on but I don't hear councillor Grandin
councillor Caston then and we'll come
back to councillor Grandin if that's
possible thank you very much chairman
yeah I just wanted to follow on from
what you just said I think for me the
most important part of this is rental
income because as as that rental income
reduces that's when it becomes less
viable investment as the as the actual
valuation of our stock may it reduce as
it may go up that um that doesn't affect
the income like the like a with the
rental this forty percent and to cover
the the interest on our lines basically
we're talking about in mid Suffolk we if
we am if we lost 60% of the income we
would just be paying our light Arum
interest on our loan and nothing else
the the the risk the major risk for me
would be if that was free were not
having a tenant in there I don't think
rental incomes are going to come down I
think these have been very well chosen
I've I've been really impressed with
these how these assets have been chosen
for the the lack of likelihood that they
would be empty for a long period of time
which I think fundamentally is the risk
of losing and you know losing them
it's rental income on this so yeah I
tend to agree with you if if you were if
you buy a house it's um and receive a
rent for that house if that rental
income doesn't change but the house
loses money on its valuation it doesn't
make a mess of a different difference to
your own bank account and yeah it's it
is is regrettable that the evaluation
that has gone down over time I was
always expecting it to reduce a little
bit as with all investments but I'm it
doesn't worry me I I don't think that
this is something that we want to talk
about an exit strategy or or look at it
is a massive issue I think I think it's
been done well and it's um yeah it's um
it's only gonna get better from now okay
a counselor had two three counselors I
think counselor Grandin then counselor
Wellum and then counselor Carter Thank
You chair sorry I was having a couple
with my mute button before yes my
concern is deferment again we are all
aware of the difficult economic
situation that we're currently entering
into and we're all aware also that a lot
of the people that are currently
receiving income from the government may
soon unfortunately be facing redundancy
which is obviously reflecting on the
health of those companies so I'm
concerned that these deferments may also
be deferment of simply not paying their
rent in the future all those companies
unfortunately going into liquidation and
so that is is one of my concerns when I
see such a high percentage of deferment
going forward thank you
okay that's of concern I hope it's been
addressed because I think the quality of
the tenants was addressed in the in the
presentation yeah who did I say next it
was counselor well and then councillor
Carter and that should be us up to date
counselor Elam Thank You chair um kirsta
Caston said if the rental income reduces
by 60% we could only just repay our
debts but as we approach 60% if we were
to approach 60% then this Shakey's had
by over I think I may have misunderstood
them I might I'll make the point in the
past councillor casting can come back
the point the point is that if we're as
we approach the point where we can only
just repay our debts to Public Works
loan board and so on the the benefit of
the tsypko is reducing as as soon as the
amount of flow of cash from SIF go to
the the districts reduces then the
benefit of having tsypko reduces so just
making the point that is we should be
worried about not sixty percent where we
couldn't service our debt to Public
Works loan borders so we should start to
worry as soon as we felt that Cisco
could not give the income in terms of
the interest on the that the loan that
we've made to Cisco and also that we
have a reducing equity and the other
thing was there's a mention of the
reducing strategy it's not necessarily
an exit strategy the the reason for my
asking this question is around such
things as if the council's decide you
that they did not wish to be involved in
let's say coffee shops or car sales or
whatever and ask for those those assets
to be to be disposed of how there ought
to be something in the business plan for
how that would be done can I ask
counselor well I'm just might
purposes I mean sorry you actually serve
specifically saying that the business
plan should contain restrictions and
exceptions on properties that with the
Pacific Ocean not invest in because that
rather seems to me to be basically
taking Cisco's job away from them
absolutely in there I know I'm just just
saying it seems that way is that what
you're suggesting
no absolutely not I'm absolutely not
saying we should alter the business plan
to take away car sales coffee shops or
restaurants or anything but just as just
as some pension funds have moved away
from investing in oil there may be there
may be a situation where men may not
come but there may be a situation where
the council's decide there's a
particular field that they don't want to
be involved in and they don't want
Safeco to be involved in in fact is if
that is the case then how would could
could we see in the business plan how
that would be done well in green areas
did councillor Caston not address that
earlier in his comment about the report
that will be coming to the council can
you remind us again councillor Caston
what that was sorry there's a bit of a
lag on the mic yes so that's coming to
cabinet and next month and it it
includes lots of fun proposals for
investigation into into different sides
of it it's it's a big document so I'm
it's it's worth a good look through and
pulling out and I ask for clarity
councillor Caston whether it has any
reference or influence upon Cisco and
its investment strategies it does talk
about the investments in general of the
council so yes I would think that would
include Cisco because it is an
investment of the council yes okay
totally sure it should just be fed
through and obviously it comes to
Council my apologies councillor well and
I just thought it was important to try
and marry those two points together you
I think they are they are different
points okay sorry
have I misunderstanding yeah we can I
does anyone else think does that do any
other members feel that it would be
advantageous to have within the business
plan some sort of strategy for reducing
selling an asset or whatever should
should the council's decide that they
don't wish to be involved in a
particular area of investment all right
that's the point to consider councillor
Carter and then councillor Gould oh yes
certainly thank you just try and get
like in my faculty together after that a
bit difficult when we're talking about
mortgage in houses and staying in at the
house when I'm thinking about my terms
of being councilors which is a
re-election every four years when
there's no guarantee that we will be in
the same house we do not know who the
next government will be when there's
going to be another election so we do
not know any so we are basically looking
and investing in somebody else's house
in the future but any mistakes we make
now is going to be affecting them later
and what we can see now how rapidly
things are changing just by covert how
we have had this instrumental change in
our of where we are working if chances
are there going to be more changes in
future it's less certainty than we had
in the past we are going to be faced by
a lot more things and we are looking at
the climate crisis climate scheme
urgency which we have announced which we
are currently acting at a glacial pace
but we are looking at we're going to
have to change our way of life and
future so we are going to be looking at
possibly further cut downs in offices
regardless of the way it's utilized
because it is more environmentally
friendly working from home we are going
to be looking at
hopefully less drivers of a drive-thru
scam so I'm quite concerned about how
this could affect us in the future and
if that's the case then I would agree
that we do need to look at a exit
strategy now to have in place in case it
does a start to implement on us because
by time it does start going belly-up we
might not be in control of the count
there but we might I have control of it
and if we don't look at these strategies
now there might it might be too late to
implementing in the future okay Catholic
Carter I've just been asked to make a
point I wonder if it might be a good
idea for you to turn your camera off
first the your daughter may be appearing
in the background and this isn't because
I have any of us being embarrassed but
it's a Sparta Lee a safeguarding issue
I'm totally freaked out that's the
reason okay that's all I just think it's
probably for the best right I'm sorry
I've lost my screen and I'm going to
have to operate by memory who did less
Unni who was ready to speak next I have
requests from people that we've already
heard from I do have one from councilor
handing him and thank you I do think
Jane was in front of me I was just going
to say I've got another meeting coming
up at 12 and so I'm I'm quite happy like
you said earlier like councilor Caston
said with how things are these are
uncertain times but anyway I would just
like to move to the recommendations in
the report and I'm happy to compose them
okay before we come back to that I would
obviously have to ask is there a
seconder for that motion and that would
be recommendations presumably one around
looking at them now 3.1 3.2 and 3.3 am I
correct there Henriette yes I believe
you are I'm just checking my I just lost
my agenda so I show three as well which
is a real pain so literally doing this
from memory Oh second net to recommend a
second before we go into any further
debate I want to address the question
and I think it's an important one of
whether part two is necessary I'll try
to explain why in the preparation and
construction of the report we moved we
make strenuous efforts with officers to
move as much as was possible from the
confidential part of the business plan
into the public session and that's in
the interest of transparency and in fact
you'll note if you look at them both
similar points are made constantly
throughout the reports and the only
fundamental differences I can see are
the confidential report contains details
of some rents and repayment schedules
which frankly I don't believe that where
they can't be in the public interest
they are they are confidential business
matters I would have to say from what
I've heard today is that and everybody
is carefully avoided those subjects that
there may not be a need for us to go
into part to in any way do I have any
thoughts from members on that subject
with you mr. chairman yes I agree to
chair I saw that Emily you had her hand
up and I just wonder if we ought to hear
from her before we go any further
by all means Emily would you have
anything to add to that am i unmuted yes
I can hear you Emily
perfect I've lost the button on my
screen I can't see anything I am
literally operating like a big phone
call accident what you're doing you're
doing a fine job of that chair it was
just a point with regards to the
recommendations and that's to say that
in the report the recommendations have
been written for councils consideration
of this matter so you just will need to
adjust the recommendation from the
committee which is essentially to just
say that you support those
recommendations being taken forward by
the council so as long as the proposer
and second are happy with
amendment that that can go forward is
the motion I'm happy with that yeah I'm
happy with that mr. chairman Alice tip
is to be frozen we just see if I can get
hold of him one moment something coming
from above just one point for Emily
while we're waiting if living is got to
go at 12:00 do you need to have the vote
as she proposed it before she leaves I
can be a little bit late but I just that
is my um that I would like to leave as
soon as I can but like I said I'm happy
to stay on for another 15 minutes or so
thanks councillor Busby and technically
the vote can be taken without the
proposer in the room once once the
motion is moved and seconded it becomes
a substantive motion that can be voted
on I'm just wondering actually if if
councillor Osborn might want to take
over as vice-chair on the beba side or
indeed councillor Elemis as the mid
Suffolk chair in in councillor macaws
absent so we can move this item on
before council adding them has to leave
it's all right I'm back at least I hope
I'm back can you hear me sir I'm fine
bill yes can hear you you can hear me
five my apologies for that literally the
screen went white and faded out okay we
are more or less agreed then that there
is no requirement for us to go into part
two we can now discuss the debate on the
proposal that we confirm the
recommendations as presented in the
report can go to council subject
obviously to any amendments any changes
that anybody wants to make but we have a
proposer and a seconder for the motion
as tabled I'm sure I don't if you can
see that my hand is raised I can see
your hand is raised Cathal well are also
councillor Gould I would like to I would
like to propose an amendment and we can
note that this this businessman will be
going on to council but I would like to
add that there should be more
information in respect of the equity the
losses and the risks before available to
councillors when they discuss the
business plan at their respective
council meetings okay so in fact I don't
know if you have that henriette the
proposal would be an amendment to add
that more information in case of the
risks equity losses etc should be
presented to Council when this paper is
presented to them councillor adding them
will you be happy to accept such an
amendment I think there's any need for
that I think you've got plenty of
information here and I think they've
been very thorough I don't know how I'm
Adrian feels but you know that's my
feeling no absolutely I agree with you I
mean it has been a thorough scrutiny of
this and the information that is
available is there so I think council
well an amendment is warranted however I
feel that it's all there so I can't see
a need to change it I don't know I mean
basically at this point counselor Wellum
you could propose an amendment and we
would take it as a separate item to be
proposed seconded and voted upon
or we could request that officers
include these matters as a matter of
course within the report because why
wouldn't they it's clear that you have
concerns in that than those directions I
think they're valid concerns but it's
not as council adding them suggests
necessary if officers are prepared to
deal with that I have a hand up from
Emily you layer perhaps you can advise
us Emily
Thank You chair actually you explained
it very well indeed
so it's essentially if if councillor
Ellen would like to put that forward as
an amendment motion he will need a
seconder to his proposal and then the
committee will need to vote on whether
or not to accept that amendment if that
motion is passed it becomes the
substantive motion if not we revert back
to you counselor had a new proposal okay
is that clear okay counselor Willem what
would you like to do yes I I have
proposed that as an amendment and I am
looking for a second and the reason that
I feel it is important and while still a
degree I have some sympathy with what
counsel handing him a counselor I just
want to say but if this does go forward
as an amendment as are as I wish it to
then that information will be available
in advance of the council meeting to all
councillors if it has to come up by me
asking the same questions in the mid
Suffolk camp council meeting then so be
it
okay in my view it would be far better
okay if all of the boat that both
councils make this information available
to all councillors
fair enough counselor after you have
your hand raised I guess they also need
to be it's the second to be amendments
oh okay so we have a proposal and a
seconder for the amendment I think the
best thing at this point then is to
conduct the vote the governance officer
will conduct the vote by councillor
Gould you wish to say something no I
think my point has been answered thank
you mister you handed stuck that's what
is all right that's okay the governance
officer will conduct the votes this will
be done by roll call in alphabetical
order Henriette right so this is on the
amendment only and the amendment only to
include more information regarding risk
equity and loans and to be more
available for councilors in the upcoming
report to the council meeting
I'll do the real coal in alphabetic
order starting chairman I say it's not a
risk equity and losses risk and losses I
do apologize responses that's fine okay
that amendment to the amendment we got
it so you will have to reply for or
against abstain for the amendment
councillor Terrance Carter for council
James Kasten against council Jane Gould
for council Katherine Brandon for
council Lavinia having ham councillor
Lavinia had and ham against against
against right counselor
Alistair McCraw against casa Mary
McLaren against casa Dave moolah against
cancer Adrian Osborne
against cancer and Keith's scarf for and
councillor Keith Whelan Oh
can we have the result of that vote
please it is total four five and against
sixth amendment is lost all right I
would still like to recommend though to
officers that their points raised by
that amendment be addressed within the
reports that comes to council but we can
do that in an informal manner I believe
and achieve much of the same objective
reducing the need for questions
so we've now come to the substantive
original proposal proposed by Lavinia
had Ingham and seconded by Adrian Osborn
if I'm correct and I'd ask the
governance officer to conduct that vote
in the same manner so chair just to
confirm this is that we support or
recommendation or the recommendations
yes that will be going to Council in due
course
okay just okay I will be reading the
roll call again in alphabetical order
you can say for against or abstain
counselor Terrence Carter I'm saying
council James Caston por causa jangled
abstain kacica through Grandin for Casa
Levin you're heading ham Oh cancer
Alistar McCraw for cancer Mary McLaren
Oh Castle Dave moolah poor counselor
Adrienne our spawn poor counselor Keith
gasps OH
Hauser Keith Waylon against and the
result of that vote and result is we
have six votes for one vote against and
two up stations which means the motion
is passed and you check that I have a
different count eight eight one two
eight four one abstention
two abstentions rather than one against
is that correct to abstention the one
against that's correct
does that concur with everybody else is
reading of it absolutely okay we're not
having to go to part two I thank members
for that and we will now be able to move
on to the next item of the agenda can I
thank all the speakers on behalf of
Cisco and all the officers involved in
presenting the report we have put you
through the mill today we've given you a
lot of questions to answer but I suppose
that's what comes with the territory
anyway look thank you very much for your
time and your efforts and we obviously
as matter of over you and scrutiny we
should be seeing you in approximately a
year's time thank you again thank you
so now we are back to the public where
don't have to worry we're never going to
have the public session so we can now
move to the confirmation of minutes and
I'm just having to find this out now
there are three sets of minutes one
permit Suffolk one of the Baber and one
for the joint overview and scrutiny
committees on the dates held on those
minutes what you're asked to do is to
vote for your respective committee
minutes on those ones but all vote for
the joint minutes
so with Keith's permission which I have
asked for in advance I must confess we
have to come to item 3 which is MOS
stroke 19 stroke 11 confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting of the mid
Suffolk overview and scrutiny committee
held on 16th of January 2020 and I
remind you only mid Suffolk members may
vote upon this so the first question is
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of those minutes sure there is
just one typo on page 9 paragraph 2011
the assistant director corporate it
should be resources corporate resources
ok can we make that change of course
thank you can I have a proposer for
those minutes yes I proposed councillor
Elam and a seconder I've see councillor
mullahs hand so that's fine that's
proposed and seconded a governance
officer can now take a roll call vote as
same procedure as before
councillor Terrence Carter for against
abstain for the minutes microphone might
be muted turquoise.i so obvious I said
for caocao James Caston for council live
in your heading ham yes so Cassiday
Beulah Oh Kawasaki scarf Oh Kawasaki Sue
Ellen
so let's tarried okay the minutes of
that meeting of being confirmed and well
I don't necessarily I will be signing
them but perhaps counselor Elam will be
signing them as he's the chair of
mid-south ergo review and scrutiny
that's okay with you is it Keith
absolutely thank you right the next item
is item 4b OS 19 stroke nine
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the beta overview and
scrutiny committee held on the 20th of
January 2020 and in this instance only
Baber members can vote first off babe
remembers are there any points regarding
the accuracy of those minutes no can I
have a proposer please propose mr.
chairman
councillor Osborn proposing second oh
that's councillor McClaren yes thank you
very much okay we can now proceed to the
roll call vote for favor same procedure
a procedure for against abstained please
councillor jingled for councillor
Katherine Grandin full cancer Alastair
macro for councillor Mary McLaren who
and council Adrienne Osborn minutes of
that meeting therefore being confirmed
and they will also be signed at the next
practical opportunity item 5 is Jos 1930
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee held on the 20th of
February 2020 and of course in this
instance both councils both councils may
vote any points regarding the accuracy
of those minutes chair there's just one
on page 26 the second line down and
planning enforcement cases were a work
in progress I think that should be thank
you thank you very much can I learn have
a proposer please
yes I proposed chef willen out of
seconder happy the second counselor
mullah okay the governance officer can
now take a roll call vote again will be
in alphabetic order for against or
abstain counselor Terrence Carter for
council James Caston for cassa jane
gould
I wasn't class yet that made you so I
don't know that that means I would have
stone you you can't vote for the minutes
then that's fine out councillor
Catherine Grandin Oh cows live in you're
heading home
counselor stomach roll for house
Adrienne Osborn
Oh house lucky scarf Oh Castle keys well
those minutes having been confirmed
they'll also be signed at the next
practicable opportunity we now move to
the end of the agenda for item ten
information bulletin but there is no
information bulletin in this month's so
item 11 is the forthcoming decisions
list particularly relevant to cabinet
functions does anyone have any comments
upon the forthcoming decisions list use
the raised hand function if you do
counselor Wellum chair I just wondered
whether we ought to consider
scrutinizing the future delivery model
for public realm in advance of cabinet
in September I don't think we need to
make a decision you know a formal
decision today but I think we should
consider your point I'm just looking at
the September arrangements the next
available I mean the latest we could do
that if coming to cabinet in September
of scrutiny need to be looking at it and
August at the latest
yeah so what I'd suggest is that we
Henriette to look into our work schedule
and program we do have items scheduled
for which will be coming to in a moment
for both of July and August
so we'll be adding on to our August
workload
Kathlyn yeah could I just ask is is
there a task and finish group or a
cross-party group looking at that
if so then scrutiny won't need to I
believe there isn't though there has
been one in the past I recall being on
one two or three years ago but it went
nowhere because the recommendations by
the then consultants were rejected by
the then administration so for the
moment I think it's something we'll have
to look at in the chairs meeting the
suggestions may do it other members have
any thoughts on that subject for the
worthy one for scrutiny yes I tend to
agree with you mr. chairman I would
agree as well it's worth looking at yes
definitely what we'll try and get is a
preliminary indication from the officers
of what might be under consideration and
then we chairs can make a judge long
with a judgement along with the Vice
chairs and on your behalf if that's all
right with you members yes okay thank
you very much
okay so I'm just going to switch between
different things
so now items twelve and thirteen which
are the two separate work plans for
Weber and mid Suffolk and I think it's
fairly clear that at the moment those
two plans are very much aligned and will
be for this effective council year
although we're crossing over slightly
now one point that came up and I'm
really glad to see that this is an
opportunity for a little pro activity
councillor McClaren sent an email to
myself and the chair of mid Suffolk
Keith Whelan on a webinar a sip far
webinar CIP FA that she attended which
dealt with some scrutiny functions I
wonder if her if you could address that
for us councillor McClaren yes Thank You
chair and I'm not sure how many of the
members were actually present webinar I
know there were few from its it work but
it was
put on by sifter understanded the in
practice Kovac 19 on your council and
the session was three and a half hours
long I was like plug in a bit at the end
but the focus was on understanding the
coronavirus and its impact its had had
on council activity and established
policies and procedures and I think this
morning we've actually looked at that in
relation to our previous item so the
subjects covered were finance
maintaining effective controls and
governance the important role of
procurement in a crisis the impact on
revenue collection and then there was a
final session which we were all in this
together
concluded by a virtual panel discussion
but the training was excellent and for
me the underlying message from all
speakers was the responsibilities of
councillors especially of those that do
audit governance and scrutiny and we
really should be not necessarily looking
only at the past but on the new normal
and the message there was that
councillors and the input of councillors
to their council should not be diluted
or diverted by other pressures that
might be happening within the council
some councils already having full
council meetings and on a personal note
I was surprised how little I knew about
procurement retrospectively and even
less about its current activity and I
thought that was a subject that might
need to be pursued I had so happy sorry
we haven't been promised a full recorded
version of the day with chatbox scripts
excellent I rang sip fir and they're in
the middle of sorting it out so it's not
ready but as soon as I guess it then I
will send it to both chair or both
the reason the reason I raised this is
that amongst our forthcoming agenda for
next month one of the items is our own
self-examination which is basically what
I call checking for lumps where we
actually scrutinize the scrutiny
function itself and I think that's a
valid and sensible point of view we've
done it in the past it's been quite
useful it's not there
dr. self-criticism whipping ourselves
nor is it to take self praise it's to
actually take a a proper look at what it
is we do in a scrutiny function and I
think by that time members will have had
a chance to see the reports and they may
be for this last year they make me
surprised but despite the lockdown that
we've been through just come under
scrutiny committees at both Weber and
mid Suffolk and jointly have achieved
this year I was surprised myself
so if we could have that with luck for
that meeting that would be very helpful
Mary because we then have a little bit
more information I think the question of
how you scrutinize a post kovat nineteen
world and the new normal is going to be
such a vast question and of course it's
going to be constantly changing as the
months go by much as the weeks have gone
by but I agree with you it is something
it's going to have to be done but how
systematically we would achieve that
without overloading ourselves I believe
you're right though we mustn't be
distracted by the day-to-day and one of
the things we've always managed in
scrutiny is to to move on where we've
done a subject more than once so we
think we have got a handle on the
subject we say right we don't need to
hear about that anymore
until something happens this is what
needs to happen and I believe we can
possibly put this into next year's
scrutiny plan going forward would that
make sense to you
thank you chair thank you no thank you
very much for going to the trouble of
doing that and to put that circulated
around we will be there right so as I've
said you are going to receive the
scrutiny report sometime ready for the
next council meeting both for the mid
Suffolk one and the Baber one as I say I
hope you'll have a chance to read
through it and take some pride in the
work that you've done and then we can
all have a look at that again in
scrutiny next month our next meeting
will be once again a joint meeting
you'll be pleased to hear chaired by
councillor Wellum and that will be on
the 20th of July 20 22 be made but I
would imagine we'll be doing something
remote like this and perhaps we'll have
got some of the bugs out of the things
and thank you very much all of you and
thanks to any members of the public who
stuck this out of watching us on YouTube
and anybody who comes to look at this in
the future thank you very much everybody
have a nice rest of the day thank you
thank you
you
you